à 19 ans sakho a enfin trouvé sa place
en 2015 ce jeune syrien a fui la guerre
qui frappait son pays après un passage
par le liban il a bénéficié du couloir
humanitaire pour arriver en france il ya
deux ans et c'est désormais à dole qu'il
apprend la mécanique s'est bien passé
c'est quoi comme sakho 17 autres élèves
sont inscrits à l'école jure alternance
en difficulté ou en recherche d'une
formation manuel ces jeunes se forment
pour des c ap en métallerie ou en
mécanique
le tout accompagné par des maîtres
professionnels issus du milieu
on est content quand ils viennent nous
voir du coup le toit tout sort mécanique
change complètement des pas de projets
c'est gratifiant et aussi pour eux
d'avoir les sens inverse revenir dans le
garage outre la pratique
les élèves ont également des cours
théoriques dans les ateliers comme en
classe les effectifs sont réduits afin
de faciliter l'accompagnement je peux me
mettre avec eux suivre exactement et
m'adapter
ceux qui ont plus besoin de lire se
complaît besoin d'écrire ce qu'ils
veulent comprendre davantage on peut
répondre à leurs questions sur le moment
et répondre aux difficultés aussi sur le
moment d'avancer une école de production
qui forme les élèves tout en travaillant
pour de vrais clients
créée il ya neuf ans la structure gérée
par l'association eco faur est installé
depuis le début de l'année dans des
nouveaux locaux
quand on a démarré on louait des
ateliers qui n'était pas qui était
éloigné de six kilomètres l'un de
l'autre et donc on avait envie d'offrir
à nos salariés à nos élèves des
meilleures conditions de travail avec
des machines pour certaines neuf et
surtout créer une dynamique d'équipé au
niveau des adultes et des élèves jour
alternant ce compte bien continuer son
travail auprès des jeunes et envisage
même de s'élargir afin de former les
générations futures au métier d'ouvrier
viticole
et surtout aussi en technologie